we saw you on television and you
remembered a ton of place okay what do
you think of Sean's brain what it's out
of this world is better than mine I can
tell you that week twelve Saints at Rams
429 in the second quarter second and
seven on the Saints seven what happens
Oh Josh Reynolds touchdown off schedule
play versus a three-man rush
you're absolutely are you kidding you're
unbelievable now we are gonna go to this
is Sean macfay time in Washington Oh
bringing it back to 2015 week seven
bucks at skins second and seven on the
Tampa Bay 24 58 seconds left in the
fourth quarter
Jameson Crowder wheeler out down the
right sideline Seamus ooh Crowder we
were out down the right sideline South
the first down and then out of that
drive ends Jordan Reed touchdown in a
four by one individual ISO slant and
what meme was that game you like that
the brain on shore amazing all right
2005 NFC wild-card game
Washington and Tampa Bay 947 left in the
third third and 2 of a Washington two
yard line well this is my play this is
their cheating to make it equal their
cheek what's the play hi bootleg out to
the left and dove in for a touchdown one
of my only member I only rushing
[Applause]
Chris was playing with the Bucks that
was my first year in coaching yeah
really remember we had some breakfast
together talk a little ball but what
didn't we get breakfast no I actually
when I worked this was before I coached
for the Bucks yeah it was when I was
working training camp the year after
they had won the Super Bowl while I was
working with it's like you know doing
the waterboy whatever everybody
remembers todd gurley screen for a
touchdown against the Cowboys what
happened the play before the big
touchdown screen and Malcolm Brown and
that is why he Shaun McMahan's